Alice: 听见了吗
Alice: Did you hear that?
Alice: 刘婷我不愿让你一个人
Alice: Liu Ting, I don't want to leave you alone
Alice: 我小子太浪漫了
Alice: My boy is too romantic
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah
Alice: 你要这香薰不要
Alice: Do you want this aromatherapy?
刘婷:啊 不用 不用 不用
Liu Ting: Ah, no, no, no
Alice: 我靠那我搁那啊
Alice: Well, then where should I put it?
Alice: 我也不想拿
Alice: I don't want to take it either
Alice: 算了我拿走吧
Alice: Fine, I'll take it
Alice: 你不要
Alice: You don't want it?
刘婷:我真不要
Liu Ting: I really don't want it
Alice: 山猪吃不来细糠
Alice: A wild boar can't appreciate fine food
Alice: 确实是这样
Alice: That's how it is
刘婷:确实是那个东西好像味比较大
Liu Ting: Yeah, that thing really has a strong smell
刘婷:耶 东西烤好了
Liu Ting: Yay, the food is done roasting
Alice: 焦了没
Alice: Is it burnt?
Alice: 我草 sorry
Alice: Oh shit, sorry
Alice: 换首歌吧
Alice: Let's change the song
Alice: 你想听啥
Alice: What do you want to listen to?
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah
Alice: 真的吗
Alice: Really?
Alice: 好我也喜欢这个歌
Alice: Cool, I like this song too
Alice: 今天晚上啊
Alice: Tonight?
Alice: 不行今天晚上估计来不及了
Alice: No way, we probably won't make it tonight
Alice: 8点它就关门了
Alice: It closes at 8
Alice: 是
Alice: Yeah
Alice: 那不然呢
Alice: What else can we do?
Alice: 让我来说
Alice: Let me say something.
Alice: 不是哪有那么多快递柜啊
Alice: There's no way there are that many package lockers.
Alice: 你想想我们那住了多少人
Alice: Think about how many people live where we do.
Alice: 我靠我感觉那中国
Alice: Oh my god, I feel like in China...
Alice: 现在还是不说这个校名了
Alice: Let's not mention the name of the school now.
Alice: 就我们学校他妈马蜂窝似的住了
Alice: Our school is like a freaking beehive with so many people living there.
Alice: 我觉得我这住宿质量不是很高
Alice: I feel like the living quality here is not that high.
Alice: 委屈
Alice: I'm feeling wronged.
Alice: 委屈呢
Alice: So wronged.
Alice: 我靠我怎么切歌了
Alice: Oh my god, why did I change the song?
Alice: 不接不接不接
Alice: I'm not answering, not answering, not answering.
刘婷:烦死了
Liu Ting: So annoying.
Alice: 不是广告人给我打视频
Alice: It's not an ad, someone video called me.
Alice: 不想接
Alice: I don't want to answer.
Alice: 忙着呢
Alice: I'm busy.
Lucia: 唱错了
Lucia: Sang the wrong lyrics.
Alice: 时光 等待
Alice: Time waits.
Alice:带上我的首饰吧
Alice: Put on my jewelry.
Alice:别吧的假呀
Alice: No, it's fake.
Alice:跟我一起唱
Alice: Sing with me.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:这个花有点浪费了
Alice: This flower is a bit of a waste.
刘婷:哪个
Liu Ting: Which one?
Alice:这个
Alice: This one.
Alice:那是
Alice: That's it.
Alice:我现在已经偏上极简主义了
Alice: I'm now leaning towards minimalism.
Alice:虽然你可能能点不信
Alice: Though you might not believe it.
刘婷:哎哎哎
Liu Ting: Hey hey hey.
Lucia:我在接下来这一个月里还要打两针
Lucia: I still need to get two more shots in the next month.
Katrina: 够了哈哈哈
Katrina: That's enough hahaha.
Alice:ego
Alice: Ego.
Katrina: 快走吧
Katrina: Hurry up, let's go.
Katrina: 修硕哈哈
Katrina: Shure hahaha.
Katrina: 被你折磨的
Katrina: You tortured him.
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye.
Shure: 拜拜
Shure: Bye-bye.
Alice:拜拜
Alice: Bye-bye.
Katrina: 别哭别哭
Katrina: Don't cry, don't cry.
Katrina: 哈哈哈别哭
Katrina: Hahaha, don't cry.
Katrina: 哈哈哈还下雨吗
Katrina: Hahaha, is it still raining?
Alice:刚刚下雨了吗
Alice: Did it rain just now?
Katrina: 哎呦脚都麻了
Katrina: Oh, my foot's gone numb.
Alice:所以刚刚在谈啥呀
Alice: So, what were we talking about?
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice:没参加也无所谓吧
Alice: It's fine if you didn't join.
Tasha:你可以报
Tasha: You can sign up.
Lucia:放心吧
Lucia: Don't worry.
粉:要笑死
Katrina: I'm going to die laughing.
Jake:拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye.
Jake:拜拜 哈哈
Jake: Bye-bye, haha.
Tasha:哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina: 生怕他们再回来烧钱
Katrina: Afraid they'll come back and waste money.
Alice:收拾东西
Alice: Pack up.
Alice:现在是要一个
Alice: Now we need one...
Alice:一个什么吗
Alice: One what?
Alice:怎么报账
Alice: How to report expenses?
Alice:是给你账单
Alice: Should I give you the bill?
Lucia:自自己加一下也行
Lucia: You can add it up yourself too.
Lucia:哈哈哈对给一个
Lucia: Haha, yeah, give it.
Jake:然后后来给一个账单也行
Jake: And then give a bill later, that's fine too.
Lucia:行行 对
Lucia: Sure, yeah.
Lucia:但是我这都是就是
Lucia: But what I have here is just...
Alice:哎呀别烦我
Alice: Oh, don't bother me.
Alice:妈的 忙着呢
Alice: Damn, I'm busy.
Lucia:我在卫生所
Lucia: I'm at the clinic.
Lucia:那是有发票的
Lucia: There are receipts for that.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:需要的话可以给你
Lucia: If you need, I can give it to you.
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need.
Alice:你可以帮我按一下
Alice: Can you press it for me?
Alice:计算器吗我不想
Alice: The calculator, I don't want to.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Alice:我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
Alice:谢谢你
Alice: Thank you.
Jake:记账台是吧
Jake: This is the accounting desk, right?
Jake:这就是账台
Jake: This is the accounting desk.
Jake:嗯记账台
Jake: Yeah, accounting desk.
Lucia:我们也要做balance shit吗难道
Lucia: Do we also have to do a balance sheet?
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia:梯子帐
Lucia: Ladder account
Alice:我把账直接发给你吧
Alice: I'll send you the account directly
Jake: 好 呃 你这个很专业
Jake: Okay, um, you're very professional
Alice:这是备忘录
Alice: This is a memo
Alice:就是也可以放图片和文字
Alice: It can also include pictures and text
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia:嗯学习学习
Lucia: Yeah, need to learn
Alice:这个
Alice: This
Katrina: 哎呀哎我们直接算了
Katrina: Oh, let's just calculate it directly
Katrina: 你需要我们订单纸那个吗
Katrina: Do you need that order paper?
Alice:备忘录里写也行
Alice: Writing in the memo is fine too
Katrina: 他不需要的话我们就直接算了
Katrina: If he doesn't need it, we'll just calculate directly
Katrina: 我先点个粥喝
Katrina: I'll order some porridge first
Katrina: 看我的红包
Katrina: Look at my red envelope
Lucia:我也可以用
Lucia: I can use it too
Katrina: 一个一新币的红包
Katrina: A one Singapore dollar red envelope
Jake:嗯啊很多哈哈
Jake: Hmm, a lot, haha
Alice:还用了满减
Alice: And used a discount
Alice:咦
Alice: Hmm
Alice:奇怪呢
Alice: Weird
Alice:我给你发一个
Alice: I'll send you one
Alice:为什么是这样的呢
Alice: Why is it like this?
Alice:给你发一个完整版的
Alice: I'll send you the full version
Katrina: 哎 想吃这个如意混沌
Katrina: Oh, I want to eat this Ru Yi wonton
Katrina: 你们吃啥
Katrina: What are you guys eating?
Jake:呃就你那个店里边
Jake: Uh, just from your store
Jake:我们再找一找
Jake: We'll look around
Katrina: 我吃如意馄饨
Katrina: I'm eating Ru Yi wonton
Katrina: 你们也吃馄饨吗
Katrina: Are you guys also eating wonton?
Katrina: 你们想吃别的可以点
Katrina: You can order something else if you want
Jake:就是吃馄饨
Jake: Just wontons
Jake:大家也没什么想
Jake: No one has other preferences
Jake:你们想吃什么也行
Jake: You can have whatever you want
Jake:馄饨就是它
Jake: Wontons it is
Alice:算了直接截图吧
Alice: Forget it, just take a screenshot
Lucia:这是啥味的
Lucia: What flavor is this?
Katrina: 虾仁的啊
Katrina: Shrimp, of course
Lucia:超派虾仁的
Lucia: Super shrimp
Katrina: 哎大馄饨应该改成小馄饨
Katrina: Oh, big wontons should be changed to small wontons
Lucia:我也要这个吧
Lucia: I'll have this too.
Lucia:我要香菜
Lucia: I want cilantro.
Lucia:我好了谢谢
Lucia: I'm done, thank you.
Katrina: 你吃吗嗯
Katrina: Are you eating this?
Katrina: 你不想吃
Katrina: You don't want to eat?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina: 你呢
Katrina: What about you?
Jake:一碗大馄饨50一颗
Jake: A bowl of big wontons, 50 each.
Lucia:sorry没事没事
Lucia: Sorry, it's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 哎没电了
Katrina: Oh, no power.
Lucia:我这也没电了
Lucia: Mine's out of power too.
Katrina: 还有多的充电宝呢
Katrina: There's still extra power banks.
Jake:有上楼
Jake: Upstairs.
Jake:随便拔
Jake: Take whichever.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Alice:老板你自己翻着看看吧我又弄成PDF
Alice: Boss, you look through it yourself. I converted it to PDF again.
Jake:好好你来
Jake: Okay, okay, you handle it.
Alice:你自己扒啦吧
Alice: You deal with it yourself.
Jake:哈哈哈你扒拉
Jake: Haha, you handle it.
Alice:因为 那个
Alice: Because of that...
Alice:一弄就变成那啥了
Alice: It just turns into that thing.
Alice:招牌吧 不要香菜
Alice: Signature dish, no cilantro.
Lucia:嗯截止到目前为止
Lucia: Hmm, up to now...
Lucia:我一个人要的香菜啊
Lucia: I'm the only one who wants cilantro, right?
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia:没事它是一份一份的对
Lucia: It's okay, it's served separately.
Jake:你你你给我哎哎
Jake: You, you, give it to me. Hey, hey.
Jake:呃 唧 好
Jake: Uh, okay.
Alice:姐
Alice: Sis.
Jake:给钱哈哈
Jake: Pay up, haha.
Jake:打钱
Jake: Transfer money.
Tasha:我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Tasha:那还不够还的
Tasha: That's still not enough to repay.
Alice:白干
Alice: All for nothing.
Jake:打钱够不够
Jake: Is the money enough?
Tasha:没没坏吧
Tasha: No, it's not broken, right?
Tasha:那就行
Tasha: Then it's fine.
Alice:白干
Alice: All for nothing.
Jake:哈哈哈那何止白干
Jake: Haha, not just for nothing.
Tasha:何止白干
Tasha: Not just for nothing.
Lucia:何止白干
Lucia: It's more than just wasted.
Alice:我跟她说一下
Alice: I'll talk to her.
Tasha:大钱没进
Tasha: The big money didn't come in.
Lucia:有种跟拼
Lucia: Have the guts to compete.
Lucia:有种在    打工
Lucia: Have the guts to work at Pinduoduo.
Lucia:然后签了竞业协议的感觉
Lucia: And then sign a non-compete agreement.
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Lucia:你们知道那个梗吗
Lucia: Do you know that joke?
Alice:你挑一个
Alice: You pick one.
刘婷:这个
Liu Ting: This one.
Alice:速度
Alice: Quick.
Alice:所以怎么弄成PDF呢
Alice: So how do you turn it into a PDF?
Jake:呃打印
Jake: Uh, print it.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Lucia:嗯备忘录吗
Lucia: Hmm, is it a memo?
Lucia:备忘录好像可以直接导出成品
Lucia: I think you can export the memo directly.
Alice:直接导出备忘录我发出的这张图片
Alice: Export the memo directly, like this picture I sent.
Jake:来来来来来
Jake: Come, come, come.
Alice:哦 它已经好了
Alice: Oh, it's done.
Jake:来给你
Jake: Here you go.
Jake:您您继续说
Jake: You, you continue.
Alice:我我我怎么弄
Alice: How, how do I do it?
Lucia:啊没事
Lucia: Ah, it's okay.
Jake:你放这我再给你
Jake: Put it here, I'll do it for you.
Jake:我给你秀一下
Jake: I'll show you.
Jake:哎接着吧备忘录
Jake: Hey, let's continue with the memo.
Alice:要干嘛
Alice: What for?
Alice:这个然后直接打印是吗
Alice: This one, then print it directly, right?
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Alice:哦这样啊
Alice: Oh, like this?
Alice:对然后呢
Alice: Yes, and then?
Jake:然后选择打印机
Jake: Then select the printer.
Jake:哦也不用
Jake: Oh, no need.
Jake:就这边直接点
Jake: Just click here.
Katrina: 点完了吗
Katrina: Done clicking?
Jake:就可以发送了
Jake: Then you can send it.
Jake:这边是pdf
Jake: This is the PDF.
Katrina: 我手机呢
Katrina: Where's my phone?
Lucia:啊哦就是就是
Lucia: Ah, oh, it's just...
Lucia:前几天网上一个新闻就是
Lucia: A few days ago there was news online about Pinduoduo...
Lucia:就是大家知道竟业协议这回事
Lucia: So everyone knows about non-compete agreements
Lucia:嗯对靖康可能知道
Lucia: Hmm, yeah, Jingkang might know
Lucia:就是啊
Lucia: Right
Lucia:薇薇之前不知道的话就是没事
Lucia: If Vivi didn't know before, it's fine
Lucia:这个反正是你到到工作的时候
Lucia: Anyway, it's something you'll use
Lucia:之后才会才会用到
Lucia: only after you start working
Lucia:所以然后就是有的大公司
Lucia: So, some big companies
Lucia:比如说就为了防止你入入职
Lucia: for example, to prevent you from joining
Lucia:跟他有竞争关系的其他公司
Lucia: other companies that are their competitors
Lucia:他在入职时候会跟你签竞业协议就要
Lucia: they will have you sign a non-compete agreement when you join
Lucia:就是防止就是这些高层员工泄露商业
Lucia: to prevent high-level employees from leaking business
Lucia:商业机密
Lucia: secrets
Lucia:他本身是这样的一个
Lucia: That's the purpose of it
Lucia:就是design purpose是这个
Lucia: The design purpose is that
Lucia:然后但是就是
Lucia: But now
Lucia:有的公司现在就开始滥用这个
Lucia: some companies are abusing this
Lucia:就是即使是基层员工入职
Lucia: even making entry-level employees
Lucia:比如说刚刚刚毕业应届生这种
Lucia: like recent graduates sign non-compete agreements
Lucia:也让他们去签竞业协议
Lucia: and because job-hopping
Lucia:然后因为其实现在就是大家换工
Lucia: is very common nowadays
Lucia:换工作是很常见的嘛
Lucia: there were many cases before
Lucia:然后就有之前就有好好好些
Lucia: where very ordinary employees
Lucia:就是其实很普通的员工
Lucia: after leaving a company
Lucia:然后他们可能从这公司离职之后
Lucia: joined a new company where their work
Lucia:然后他进入了一个实际上吧
Lucia: wasn't really related to their old company's business
Lucia:他负责的业务
Lucia: their new company
Lucia:可能跟之前公司也不是那么相关的
Lucia: but since they were just entry-level workers
Lucia:这么的新公司
Lucia: they didn't hold any business secrets
Lucia:然后就是而且他们就是基层打工人
Lucia: yet their old company sued them using the non-compete agreement
Lucia:所以手上也没有什么商业机密
Lucia: and made them pay money
Lucia:但是他们的员工司
Lucia: So it was all for nothing
Lucia:就拿这个竞业协议去起诉他们
Lucia: they worked for nothing
Lucia:然后让他们赔钱
Lucia: and still had to pay their old company
Lucia:就相当于是白干
Lucia: It's like working for free
Jake: 白干啊
Jake: For free?
Lucia:对相当于不光白干
Lucia: Yeah, not only for free
Lucia:还要给员工公司赔钱
Lucia: but also having to pay
Lucia:就这个事情
Lucia: their old company
Lucia:前段时间
Lucia: So recently
Lucia:反正网上说了好几个这样的例子
Lucia: there have been several cases like this discussed online
Lucia:都是我刚才说的那个
Lucia: It's what I just mentioned.
Lucia:我就不说一遍了
Lucia: I won't repeat it.
Lucia:这样一会你方便剪
Lucia: This way, it will be easier for you to edit later.
Lucia:哈哈哈好好
Lucia: Hahaha, alright.
Lucia:我场记一下
Lucia: Let me make a note.
Lucia:我还是挺害怕他们来找我的
Lucia: I'm actually quite scared that they'll come looking for me.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:我没有
Alice: I don't have it.
Jake:没有没有我把
Jake: No, no, I...
Jake:我们把    给逼掉就行
Jake: We'll just block out Pinduoduo.
Jake:我们把逼给逼掉就行
Jake: We'll just block it out.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:杨老板我来算算你八字吧
Alice: Jake, let me read your fortune.
Jake:啊好啊
Jake: Oh, sure.
Katrina: 你会算这个
Katrina: You know how to do that?
Jake:怎么算
Jake: How do you do it?
Alice:一点点
Alice: Just a little bit.
Katrina: 你得给我来
Katrina: You have to do mine too.
Katrina: 感觉你有点小魔女的感觉
Katrina: You seem a bit like a little witch.
Jake:请坐请坐
Jake: Please, have a seat.
Alice:哦不用不用不用不用不用不用不用哎呀
Alice: Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Jake:请坐大师
Jake: Please sit, master.
Jake:大师请坐
Jake: Master, have a seat.
Lucia:但我
Lucia: But I...
Jake:哈哈大师不得坐着的
Jake: Hahaha, the master should be seated.
Jake:站着大师
Jake: The master stands?
Jake:没见过站着大师
Jake: Never seen a standing master.
Alice:但你得
Alice: But you need to...
Lucia:但是
Lucia: But...
Alice:你知道你的出生时间吗
Alice: Do you know your birth time?
Jake:我好像不知道
Jake: I don't think I do.
Alice:那拜
Alice: Then it's useless.
Jake:好再见
Jake: Okay, bye.
Alice:白搭 直接白搭
Alice: It's pointless, completely pointless.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 可以算我的吗
Katrina: Can you do mine?
Katrina: 我知道我是农历还是阳历
Katrina: I know if it's lunar or solar.
Alice:呃你得出精确到时间
Alice: Uh, you need to be precise to the time.
Katrina: 我下午1点出生的
Katrina: I was born at 1 PM.
Alice:下午1点可以
Alice: 1 PM is fine.
Alice:1点前一点后
Alice: A little before 1 o'clock, a little after
Katrina: 一点零几分了
Katrina: It's a little past 1 now
Alice:马上
Alice: Almost
Lucia:不过法律意义上说我这应该不算造谣
Lucia: But legally speaking, this shouldn't count as spreading rumors
Lucia:因为
Lucia: Because
Lucia:我只是复述了我在网上看到的信息
Lucia: I'm just repeating what I saw online
Alice:那你的生日是
Alice: So, when's your birthday?
Katrina: 嗯阳历还是农历
Katrina: Um, solar calendar or lunar calendar?
Katrina: 阳历2001
Katrina: Solar, 2001
Lucia:反正我好多同学都是学法的
Lucia: Anyway, a lot of my classmates study law
Lucia:都够组一个律师团了
Lucia: We could form a whole legal team
Alice:91年12月
Alice: December 1991
Alice:21
Alice: 21st
Alice:下午1点
Alice: 1 PM
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah
Alice:1点啊 1点无所谓
Alice: 1 PM, 1 PM, it doesn't matter
Alice:1点几分都一样
Alice: A few minutes past 1 is the same
Alice:这个不用
Alice: Not for this
Lucia:现在等饭
Lucia: Now we wait for food
Tasha:哦对你们点饭了 哎
Tasha: Oh right, you guys ordered food, huh
Lucia:你刚才没点吗
Lucia: Didn't you order?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Yeah
Katrina: 那你可以睡觉
Katrina: Then you can take a nap
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Tasha:今天睡了一下午好爽啊
Tasha: Napping all afternoon was great
Jake:是确实
Jake: It really was
Katrina: 而且醒来都都下雨了
Katrina: Plus, it was raining when I woke up
Jake:下雨天适合睡觉
Jake: Rainy days are perfect for sleeping
Alice:请求超时
Alice: Request timed out
Alice:等会吧
Alice: Let's wait a bit
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah
Alice:无妨
Alice: No worries
Alice:我们是现场报销吗
Alice: Do we get reimbursed on the spot?
Jake:可以
Jake: We can
Katrina: 我正在算
Katrina: I'm calculating
Katrina: 哎呦 哎我买一支彩色笔好像没看见
Katrina: Oh, I bought a colored pen, but I didn't see it
Katrina: 一支彩色笔
Katrina: A colored pen
Alice:是没送吗
Alice: It wasn't delivered?
Katrina: 哎取了取了
Katrina: Oh, I got it
Katrina: 我听谁说
Katrina: I heard someone say
Lucia:好像看见了
Lucia: It seems like I saw it
Lucia:但是
Lucia: But
Katrina: 我没用
Katrina: I didn't use it
Lucia:后来又放哪去就不知道了
Lucia: Later, I don't know where it was put
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:这边还有一袋
Jake: There's another bag here
Jake:不知道是什么
Jake: I don't know what it is
Jake:不知道谁垫的
Jake: Don't know who placed it here
Katrina: 我的我的
Katrina: It's mine, it's mine
Katrina: 我今天早上找我的牙膏没找到
Katrina: I was looking for my toothpaste this morning but couldn't find it
Lucia:哦我还买了碘伏和生理盐水
Lucia: Oh, I also bought iodine and saline
Lucia:不过那东西会也只有我用了
Lucia: But I'm the only one who uses it
Lucia:没事就算我那个啥也行
Lucia: It's okay, I can use it anyway
Lucia:反正他也就一新币
Lucia: After all, it's just one dollar
Tasha:一新币
Tasha: One dollar
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yes
Alice:一新币
Alice: One dollar
Lucia:算了不管他了
Lucia: Forget it, nevermind
Lucia:不算了
Lucia: Doesn't matter
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Jake:对回新加坡少坐一次公交车
Jake: Yeah, when we go back to Singapore, we can skip a bus ride
Jake:少坐半次公交车
Jake: Skip half a bus ride
Katrina: 然后我还买了花呢
Katrina: And I also bought flowers
Katrina: 也没多少
Katrina: Not many though
Lucia:我美团上的单子比较少刚就忘
Lucia: I had fewer orders on Meituan, just forgot
Lucia:算了不也没关系
Lucia: Forget it, it's okay
Lucia:哈哈哈不用
Lucia: Hahaha no need
Lucia:争取用这个哈哈哈
Lucia: Try to use this hahaha
Lucia:觉得我现在又饱又饿好奇怪啊
Lucia: I feel both full and hungry, it's so weird
Jake:就是几个胃
Jake: It's like having several stomachs
Lucia:其实我有点想吃东西
Lucia: Actually, I kind of want to eat something
Lucia:但是就是我没有那种特别饿的感觉
Lucia: But I don't feel very hungry
Alice:上面还有提拉米苏
Alice: There's still some tiramisu upstairs
Lucia:刚才吃了一大块
Lucia: I just ate a big piece
Tasha:好腻刚刚吃了一块
Tasha: It's so rich, I just had a piece
Jake:最多吃一个
Jake: The most you can eat is one
Alice:很甜蜜呵呵
Alice: It's very sweet, haha
Jake:那确实一天最多吃一个
Jake: Yeah, one per day is the max
Lucia:很好吃但是吃多了确实会有一点
Lucia: It's really good but eating too much can be a bit...
Lucia:太甜了
Lucia: Too sweet.
Lucia:糖分摄入超标
Lucia: Sugar intake over the limit.
Tasha:然后今天晚上就把房子拆了就行是吧
Tasha: So, we just need to demolish the house tonight, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha:那我现在去拆
Tasha: Then I'll start demolishing now.
Tasha:然后晚上就不用拆了
Tasha: So we don't have to do it tonight.
Jake:对 好
Jake: Yes, good.
Jake:现在拆吧
Jake: Start now.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Alright, alright.
Lucia:冲冲冲
Lucia: Go, go, go!
Alice:可以报账吗老板
Alice: Can I get reimbursed, boss?
Jake:可以报
Jake: Yes, you can.
Jake:请报
Jake: Please do.
Alice:怎么报
Alice: How do I do that?
Jake:就你你给我那PDF你给个
Jake: Just give me that PDF, you know, the total account.
Jake:总帐呗
Jake: The summary account.
Katrina: 我这个太杂了
Katrina: Mine is too messy.
Katrina: 我天
Katrina: Oh my.
Alice:就在568.19 刚摁的计算器
Alice: It's just 568.19, I just pressed the calculator.
Jake:就就这些是吧 对
Jake: So that's it, right? Yes.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Alice:牛逼
Alice: Awesome.
Jake:恭喜结账成功
Jake: Congratulations on successfully checking out.
Katrina: 20 21
Katrina: 20, 21.
Alice:OK了
Alice: Okay, done.
Alice:哇听见田螺姑娘了
Alice: Wow, I heard the snail girl.
Alice:你是在帮我
Alice: Are you helping me?
刘婷:是
Liu Ting: Yes.
Alice:哇塞
Alice: Wow.
Alice:别真爱上了
Alice: Don't fall in love for real.
Alice:我要听歌
Alice: I want to listen to music.
Alice:我真爱上你了
Alice: I'm really falling for you.
Alice:咋办啊卧槽
Alice: What should I do, oh crap.
Alice:这不弄掉了吗
Alice: Didn't you remove it?
刘婷:啊对搞掉了
Liu Ting: Oh yes, it's removed.
刘婷:你别 你别识别成同性恋了一会识别成功
Liu Ting: Don't, don't let it recognize you as gay, it might succeed 性别问题.
Alice:我这样像同性恋吗
Alice: Do I look like a lesbian like this? 性别问题
刘婷:you
Liu Ting: you
Alice:不太像我觉得
Alice: I don't think I really do. 性别问题
Alice:you
Alice: you
刘婷:唉你这床单是绑在上面的
Liu Ting: Hey, your bed sheet is tied on the top.
Alice:高级吗
Alice: Is it fancy?
刘婷:高级
Liu Ting: Fancy.
刘婷:弄
Liu Ting: Fix it.
Alice:铺
Alice: Spread it.
Alice:我要花朝里外
Alice: I want flowers inside out.
刘婷:真是讲究啊
Liu Ting: You really care about the details.
刘婷:ok
Liu Ting: OK.
Alice:回去还得洗
Alice: Still need to wash it when I get back.
刘婷:给我
Liu Ting: Give it to me.
Alice:你叠的有褶褶
Alice: You folded it with creases.
Alice:算算算就这样
Alice: Never mind, just leave it like this.
Alice:我怎么啦
Alice: What's wrong with me?
Alice:我是一个有品质的小姑娘
Alice: I'm a girl with standards.
Alice:枕头套呢
Alice: Where's the pillowcase?
刘婷:枕头套
Liu Ting: The pillowcase.
刘婷:桌上桌上
Liu Ting: On the table, on the table.
Alice:哪有桌子啊
Alice: What table?
刘婷:我怎么晓得
Liu Ting: How should I know?
Alice:OK
Alice: OK.
Alice:你当时怎么套的啊你不会是
Alice: How did you put it on? You didn't...
Alice:我自己啊
Alice: Do it myself?
Alice:我还能是谁啊
Alice: Who else would do it?
Alice:又没人帮我
Alice: No one helped me.
Alice:这个我不太感觉
Alice: I don't really feel...
Alice:不太好叠
Alice: It's hard to fold.
Alice:他有那个吱吱愣愣的
Alice: It's all crinkly.
Alice:拆
Alice: Remove it.
刘婷:感觉这个应该也不是特别有褶的面料
Liu Ting: I think this fabric shouldn't wrinkle much.
Alice:这绿色好好看啊
Alice: This green is so pretty.
Alice:就这样叠
Alice: Just fold it like this.
刘婷:就这个角
Liu Ting: Just this corner.
Alice:它有裙
Alice: It has a skirt.
Alice:直接用这个这个这个这个这个
Alice: Just use this, this, this, this, this.
Alice:OK OK
Alice: OK, OK.
Alice:别管别管
Alice: Leave it, leave it.
Alice:我靠
Alice: Oh crap.
Alice:今天晚上真是一点
Alice: Tonight really is...
Alice:哎呦卧槽
Alice: Oh damn.
Alice:一卷
Alice: One roll
Alice:穿这个会不会冷啊
Alice: Won't this be cold to wear?
Alice:有点
Alice: A little
Alice:但我没有别的了
Alice: But I don't have anything else
刘婷:毛 毛衣
Liu Ting: A sweater
刘婷:毛衣
Liu Ting: Sweater
Alice:最多也就加一层
Alice: At most, I can add one more layer
Alice:我电脑在哪
Alice: Where's my computer?
Alice:还我的
Alice: Give me back mine
Alice:我的牙膏牙刷有人吗
Alice: Does anyone have my toothpaste and toothbrush?
Alice:得想想怎么装进去
Alice: I need to think about how to pack this
Alice:呀 我的白衣服啊
Alice: Ah, my white clothes!
Alice:啊 啊
Alice: Ah, ah
Alice:拿出来使
Alice: Take it out and use it
Alice:哎呀回去还要收拾寝室
Alice: Oh man, I still have to tidy up the dorm
Alice:我真是服了
Alice: I'm really fed up
Alice:卧槽
Alice: Oh crap
刘婷:没事能折反正这玩意
Liu Ting: It's okay, you can fold it anyway
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Alice:哎就这样
Alice: Oh well, just like this
Alice:哎我的袜子
Alice: Oh, my socks
Alice:干什么
Alice: What are you doing?
Alice:搞性骚扰是吗
Alice: Are you harassing me? 性别问题
Alice:哎呀衣服放这
Alice: Ah, put the clothes here
Alice:算了就这样吧
Alice: Forget it, just leave it
Alice:对啊
Alice: Yeah
刘婷:你电脑是裸着放进去的吗
Liu Ting: Did you put your computer in there without a cover?
Alice:这个
Alice: This
刘婷:啊
Liu Ting: Ah
Alice:哎累呀
Alice: Oh, I'm tired
Alice:都放下了
Alice: All set
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Alice:哦对还有香薰
Alice: Oh right, there's also the incense
Alice:哎哟哎哟
Alice: Oh man, oh man
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh man
Alice:这根不要棍不要
Alice: This stick, don't need it
Alice:因为没法拿
Alice: Because I can't carry it
Alice:你能把它塞进去吗
Alice: Can you stuff it in?
刘婷:easy
Liu Ting: Easy
Alice:easy
Alice: Easy
刘婷:这什么花还挺好看的
Liu Ting: This flower is quite pretty.
刘婷:什么楠
Liu Ting: What kind of nan is this?
Alice:你要拿走
刘婷:啊那到不至于
Liu Ting: Ah, that's not necessary.
Alice:我觉得好像有点够呛
Alice: I think it might be a bit tough.
Alice:但是好像又很可以
Alice: But it seems doable.
Alice:对还有
Alice: Yes, and...
Alice:这个要不不搁到
Alice: Should we put this...
Alice:那行李箱
Alice: In that suitcase?
Alice:这个都可以搁那啥
Alice: These can all be put there.
Alice:对啊网兜呢
Alice: Yeah, where's the net bag?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:好了等会再收拾吧
Alice: Alright, let's tidy up later.
Alice:哎呦累死了
Alice: Oh, I'm exhausted.
Alice:为什么没干啥就觉得很累呢
Alice: Why do I feel so tired even though I didn't do much?
刘婷:怎么没干啥
Liu Ting: What do you mean you didn't do much?
Alice:什么意思
Alice: What do you mean?
Alice:看外面还有啥要收拾的
Alice: Look outside, is there anything else to clean up?
Alice:对啊
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:嗯 这个
Alice: Hmm, this...
Alice:这还有什么需要收拾的吗
Alice: Is there anything else that needs tidying up?
Alice:这个
Alice: This...
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Katrina: 你可以拿点东西回去
Katrina: You can take some stuff back.
Alice:拿什么拿什么
Alice: Take what? Take what?
Katrina: 想拿什么拿什么
Katrina: Whatever you want.
Alice:就是这些用不太上吧
Alice: These might not be very useful.
Katrina: 拿点咖啡啊啥的
Katrina: Take some coffee or something.
Alice:咖啡对哦
Alice: Coffee, oh right.
Alice:他那个啥拿走没呀
Alice: Did he take his stuff?
Alice:他需要那个什么手冲的那些东西
Alice: He needs those pour-over coffee things.
Katrina: 那是他自己的那个魔法豆豆的那个
Katrina: Those are his own magic beans or whatever.
Alice:哦哦我的意思是他需要的原料啥
Alice: Oh, I mean the ingredients he needs.
Alice:他可以拿走点
Alice: He can take some.
Alice:因为我里面有那个机器
Alice: Because I have the machine inside.
Alice:薇薇你需要给你收拾点啥东西吗
Alice: Tasha, do you need me to pack anything for you?
Alice:我现在收拾啥
Alice: What should I pack now?
Tasha:不用我房间也收拾好了
Tasha: No need, I already packed my room.
Alice:你这些原料什么的你看你就用得上了
Alice: You see, you can use these ingredients.
Jake:嘿嘿嘿
Jake: Hehe.
Jake:外边有只猫
Jake: There's a cat outside.
Jake:喂猫的
Jake: Feeding the cat.
Alice:真的吗嗯
Alice: Really?
Alice:咪咪
Alice: Kitty.
Alice:跑了
Alice: It ran away.
Alice:老板你还需要什么打扫的吗
Alice: Boss, do you need any more cleaning?
Alice:我们走了之后可就没人给你打扫
Alice: Once we leave, no one will clean for you.
Jake:我觉得
Jake: I think...
Jake: 很好
Jake: It's good.
Jake:你觉得呢
Jake: What do you think?
Alice:我不知道啊
Alice: I don't know.
Jake:我觉得我觉得我打扫不出这个样子
Jake: I think I can't clean like this.
Alice:啊真的吗
Alice: Really?
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:好嗯
Alice: Okay.
Jake:觉得已经很猛了
Jake: I think it's already pretty good.
Alice:这些锅碗瓢不知啥是我们买的
Alice: Are these pots and pans ours or his?
Alice:还是他这有的
Alice: Or did he have them?
Jake:有一部分是我们买的
Jake: Some of them are ours.
Alice:关键这也拿走没啥用啊
Alice: But there's no point in taking them.
Jake:想拿就拿
Jake: Take them if you want.
Jake:随便拿点
Jake: Just take some.
Katrina: 哎呦喝吃点西瓜又不太舒服
Katrina: Oh no, eating watermelon made me feel unwell.
Alice:拿来也没有用啊
Alice: There's no point in taking them.
Alice:用不上主要是家不在这
Alice: We don't need them, mainly because our home isn't here.
Alice:小姐姐
Alice: Missy.
刘婷:hello美女
Liu Ting: Hello, beauty.
Alice:录着呢啊
Alice: We're recording, you know.
刘婷:所以我没有说很过份的话
Liu Ting: That's why I didn't say anything too much.
Alice:小姐姐你小姐姐
Alice: Missy, you...
Alice:你小姐姐你
Alice: You...
Alice:好像又不下了
刘婷:嗯
Liu Ting: Hmm.
Alice:是吗
Alice: Really?
刘婷:这怎么有点晕车感觉呢
Liu Ting: Why does it feel a bit like motion sickness?
Alice:神经啊你
Alice: You're being neurotic.
刘婷:嗯这个世界怎么了
Liu Ting: What's wrong with this world?
刘婷:哈哈摄像头直冲着我
Liu Ting: Haha, the camera is right in my face.
Alice:调整一下换个方向
Alice: Adjust it, change the direction.
刘婷:你会算这玩意
Liu Ting: Can you calculate this thing?
Alice:你觉得我像啥也不懂的吗
Alice: Do you think I'm clueless or something?
刘婷:你怎么哪个方面都有涉及
Liu Ting: How come you know a bit about everything?
Alice:我EFP是这样的
Alice: That's how my EFP is.
刘婷:算八字我一般就直接上测字上面就搜运势几个字
Liu Ting: When it comes to fortune-telling, I usually just search for "fortune" on a character-testing app.
刘婷:你不是真会算吧
Liu Ting: You don't really know how to do it, right?
刘婷:咋了命由我不由天还看啥
Liu Ting: Why bother? I believe in controlling my own fate.
Alice:我命由天不由我
Alice: I think fate controls me.
Alice:对待会走的时候记得提醒我换鞋
Alice: By the way, remind me to change my shoes later.
Alice:绝了老妹
Alice: Amazing, girl.
Alice:忘了你存在
Alice: Forgot you were here.
Alice:这没什么
Alice: It's no big deal.
Alice:可用的东西
Alice: Useful stuff.
Alice:什么鬼这是
Alice: What the heck is this?
Alice:啊还有水
Alice: Oh, there's water too.
Alice:躺会吧小姐姐
Alice: Take a rest, girl.
Alice:又下起来了
Alice: It's raining again.
Lucia:咪咪
Lucia: Meow.
Alice:喵喵
Alice: Meow.
Alice:咪咪
Alice:喵喵
Alice: Meow.
Alice:小喵喵
Alice: Little meow meow.
Alice:喵喵
Alice: Meow.
Alice:咪咪咪咪喵喵喵
Alice: Meow meow meow meow.
Alice:吃吧
Alice: Eat up.
Alice:喵喵
Alice: Meow.
Alice:吃吧吃吧别怕
Alice: Eat up, don't be scared.
Alice:可以吃可以吃可以吃
Alice: You can eat, you can eat, you can eat.
Alice:别怕呀
Alice: Don't be scared.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:吃吧吃吧可以吃
Alice: Eat up, you can eat it.
Lucia:哎听这声音
Lucia: Oh, listen to that sound.
Alice:算了不看他了
Alice: Forget it, don't look at him.
Alice:看他他又不吃
Alice: He won't eat if you look.
Alice:把这个收回去吧
Alice: Let's put this away.
Alice:波比波比波波比波
Alice: Bop bop bop bop bop.
Alice:嗯Lucia
Alice: Hmm, Lucia.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:你要
Alice: Do you
Alice:需要帮忙收拾东西吗
Alice: need help tidying up?
Tasha:可能我还真的需要一个帮手
Tasha: Maybe I really do need a helper.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Lucia:需要你来陪我玩
Lucia: I need you to play with me.
Alice:玩 玩什么
Alice: Play what?
Lucia:玩
Lucia: Play
Alice:猫捉老鼠
Alice: Cat and mouse.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah
Lucia:可以谁当猫谁当老鼠
Lucia: Sure, who will be the cat and who will be the mouse?
Jake: 猫捉老鼠
Jake: Cat and mouse.
Alice:我当狗反正
Alice: I'll be the dog anyway.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia:我要把这个拿上去
Lucia: I'm going to take this upstairs.
Lucia:要跟我一起来吗
Lucia: Do you want to come with me?
Alice:可以我可以帮你们收拾
Alice: Sure, I can help you clean up.
Alice:我差不多了
Alice: I'm almost done.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Alice:你需要吗
Alice: Do you need help?
Katrina: 我收拾完了快
Katrina: I'm almost done cleaning up.
Lucia:嗯大家都这么快
Lucia: Hmm, everyone is so fast.
Alice:来吧
Alice: Come on.
Alice:冲冲冲冲
Alice: Let's go, go, go!
Lucia:我其实是想试一下
Lucia: I actually want to try something.
Lucia:这箱子能不能装下我的那个啥
Lucia: To see if this box can fit my stuff.
Lucia:我该拆的东西倒也不是特别的多
Lucia: I don't have too many things to unpack.
Lucia:就把墙上那些都取下来就行
Lucia: Just taking down the things on the wall will do.
Lucia:但关键就是我有一个这个
Lucia: But the key thing is I have this.
Lucia:我要把它
Lucia: I need to
Lucia:对不起
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia:这个可以这样
Lucia: This can be like this.
Lucia:先随便盖一下
Lucia: Just cover it for now.
Lucia:推到一边就好
Lucia: Push it to the side.
Lucia:我把你的礼物盒粘在那里了
Lucia: I stuck your gift box there.
Alice:你需要帮
Alice: Do you need help?
Alice:你那个需要拆吗
Alice: Do you need to take that down?
Alice:呃这个要拆的
Alice: Uh, this needs to come down.
Lucia:好我上去吧
Lucia: Okay, I'll go up.
Lucia:好的谢谢你
Alice:啊呀
Alice: Oh no.
Lucia:糟糕这个放不下
Lucia: Oh no, this won't fit.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:你是要寄回去还是拿回去啊
Alice: Are you going to mail it back or take it back?
Lucia:我没想好
Lucia: I haven't decided yet.
Lucia:我觉得这个这个东西比较占地方
Lucia: I think this thing takes up a lot of space.
Lucia:我可能啧拿可能不太方便
Lucia: It might be inconvenient to take it.
Lucia:但是系的话其实也不是很方便
Lucia: But mailing it isn't very convenient either.
Lucia:所以先这样放一下
Lucia: So I'll just leave it here for now.
Lucia:珠子
Lucia: Beads.
Lucia:我刚才光把那个柜子拆拆掉就很费力
Lucia: It took a lot of effort to just dismantle that cabinet earlier.
Alice:应该把刘婷叫上来
Alice: We should have called Liu Ting up.
Lucia:没事已经差不多了
Lucia: It's okay, it's almost done.
Alice:看着她闲我难受
Alice: Watching her idle makes me uncomfortable.
Lucia:你们是本科同学还是
Lucia: Are you guys college classmates or...
Lucia:不是我们是可以偶然的
Lucia: No, we just met by chance.
Lucia:偶然认识的
Lucia: By chance.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Alice:偶然间就我们俩才认识一个多月
Alice: We just met a little over a month ago.
Alice:俺俩竟然已经同床共枕了
Alice: And we've already been sharing the same bed.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: It's no big deal.
Lucia:我以为你们认识好长时间
Lucia: I thought you guys had known each other for a long time.
Lucia:可能是舍友真的特别熟
Lucia: Maybe roommates get really close.
Alice:其实才认识一个多月
Alice: Actually, we just met a little over a month ago.
Alice:但我们两个已经嗯同床共枕了
Alice: But we've already been sharing the same bed.
Alice:但有的人就是觉得跟他很快就能很好的朋友
Alice: Some people just become good friends quickly.
Lucia:对是的啊
Lucia: Yeah, right.
Alice:波比波啊哈哈
Alice: Boppy bo, haha.
Lucia:而且有的朋友
Lucia: And some friends...
Alice:什么扎着我的脚啊
Alice: Something's pricking my foot.
Lucia:小心没事啊
Lucia: Be careful, it's okay.
Alice:浅浅的不是那种锋利的
Alice: It's shallow, not sharp.
Alice:只是有点硌
Alice: Just a bit poky.
Alice:脚脚
Alice: On my foot.
Lucia:这可能是这个
Lucia: It might be this thing.
Alice:没事你先待会再收拾吧
Alice: It's okay, clean it up later.
Alice:因为我还没给你弄完呢
Alice: Because I haven't finished for you yet.
Alice:你到时候再
Alice: You can do it later.
Lucia:这个美纹纸胶性其实还挺强的
Lucia: This masking tape is actually quite strong.
Lucia:就是如果粘的时间长了
Lucia: If it sticks for a long time...
Alice:小心点吧
Alice: Be careful.
Lucia:它就会在那个地方
Lucia: It will leave residue on that spot.
Alice:反正我的东西就那些小装饰
Alice: Anyway, my stuff is just those little decorations.
Alice:那个桌布啊啥的
Alice: Like that tablecloth and stuff.
Alice:我就让刘婷拿回她家了
Alice: I asked Liu Ting to take them home.
Lucia:哦她家就在北京是吧
Lucia: Oh, her home is in Beijing, right?
Alice:对刘婷他家有个比这还大的别墅
Alice: Yes, Liu Ting's house is even bigger than this villa.
Lucia:哇好好
Lucia: Wow, that's great.
Alice:真是的深藏不露
Alice: Really, she hides it well.
Alice:来到这我才知道
Alice: I only knew when I came here.
Alice:她说她家也有一个这样的
Alice: She said her home has one like this too.
Lucia:下次可以去她家吗
Lucia: Can we visit her house next time?
Alice:不知道哈哈
Alice: Don't know, haha.
Lucia:开玩笑
Lucia: Just kidding.
Alice:她家在昌平我把她家记错了
Alice: Her house is in Changping, I got it wrong.
Alice:她还怨了我呢
Alice: She even blamed me for it.
Alice:我总觉得她是房山的
Alice: I always thought she was from Fangshan.
Alice:她说她没去过房山
Alice: She said she's never been to Fangshan.
Lucia:哎我我有一个舍友也是
Lucia: Hey, I have a roommate like that too.
Alice:坏了我在这说她坏话她不知道
Alice: Oh no, I'm talking bad about her and she doesn't know.
Alice:她应该不知道
Alice: She probably doesn't know.
Alice:刘婷可好玩了
Alice: Liu Ting is really fun.
Alice:刘婷看着大大咧咧的但是很细心
Alice: Liu Ting looks carefree but she's very meticulous.
Alice:很
Alice: Very
Alice:体贴
Alice: considerate.
Lucia:感觉她好好
Lucia: She seems so nice.
Lucia:对感觉大家都好好
Lucia: Yeah, everyone seems so nice.
Lucia:但是你们俩真的就是
Lucia: But you two are really like
Alice:臭味相投
Alice: Two peas in a pod.
Alice:不是特别合拍觉得
Alice: Not really a perfect match though.
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Lucia:所以我真的以为你们好像就很熟
Lucia: So I really thought you guys were really close.
Lucia:可能是认识好长时间的朋友那种
Lucia: Like friends who have known each other for a long time.
Alice:她拉屎没带纸
Alice: She forgot to bring toilet paper once.
Alice:点名让我去
Alice: And specifically called me.
Alice:哈哈哈递纸
Alice: Haha, to bring her paper.
Alice:我真服了
Alice: I was really impressed.
Lucia:哎呀好多东西啊
Lucia: Oh, there's so much stuff.
Alice:慢慢来嗯
Alice: Take your time, yeah.
Lucia:这地底下掉了个啥玩意
Lucia: Something fell under here.
Lucia:哦竟然是我的鞋
Lucia: Oh, it's my shoe.
Lucia:算了一会再管它
Lucia: Never mind, I'll get it later.
Alice:你买好
Alice: Did you buy it?
Alice:哦呦小心
Alice: Oh, be careful!
Alice:没事呦呦呦
Alice: It's okay, it's okay.
Alice:重心不稳
Alice: You're a bit unsteady.
Alice:你买好回家的票了吗
Alice: Did you buy your ticket home?
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No.
Lucia:但是我肯定明天就回家了
Lucia: But I'm definitely going home tomorrow.
Alice:不急
Alice: No rush.
Lucia:我现在没决定好哪一趟
Lucia: I haven't decided which train yet.
Lucia:因为咱们这
Lucia: Because from here...
Lucia:我查了一下
Lucia: I checked.
Lucia:从咱们这到北京西站大概一个多小时
Lucia: It takes about an hour from here to Beijing West Station.
Lucia:但我不知道我几点钟能出发
Lucia: But I don't know what time I can leave.
Lucia:所以还没买
Lucia: So I haven't bought it yet.
Alice:我觉得一个小时都比较正常了
Alice: I think an hour is pretty normal.
Lucia:而且因为东西还没完全收拾好
Lucia: And I haven't packed everything yet.
Alice:啊啊那边还有
Alice: Ah, there's more over there.
Lucia:啊那我也上去好了
Lucia: Oh, then I'll go up too.
Lucia:我这边网那些也拆好了
Lucia: I've taken down all the nets here.
Alice:没事大的
Alice: No worries, it's all good.
Lucia:这我你看我都没敢那个啥
Lucia: Look, I didn't dare to...
Lucia:我这按一下这按了一下啊
Lucia: I just pressed this here.
Alice:还都是那个啥的
Alice: They're all like that.
Lucia:对看他都是撕的
Lucia: Yeah, see, they're all torn.
Lucia:因为就是这几张是那种就是有白底的
Lucia: Because these few have white backgrounds.
Alice:对如果上面有白底
Alice: Yeah, if there's a white background.
Lucia:就很容易明显的看出来
Lucia: It's easy to notice.
Alice:撕这个就得快准狠
Alice: You need to rip it quickly and precisely.
Alice:越慢越不好撕
Lucia:好有经验
Lucia: You have a lot of experience.
Lucia:那几张都是就是
Lucia: Those few are just...
Alice: 好了还有什么需要弄掉的吗
Alice: Okay, is there anything else we need to remove?
Lucia:啊可以了
Lucia: Ah, that's it.
Lucia:然后剩下我可能就
Lucia: Then the rest, I'll probably just...
Alice:你要收拾
Alice: You need to pack.
Lucia:对收拾收拾装一装
Lucia: Yeah, pack up and load.
Lucia:不过装箱子其实好装
Lucia: But packing the box is actually easy.
Alice:ok
Alice: Okay.
Lucia:因为因为就是有一些零碎的
Lucia: Because there are some odds and ends.
Lucia:这种一次性用品就不要了
Lucia: These disposable items, we don't need them.
Alice:好现在可以做什么
Alice: Okay, so what can we do now?
Jake:来帮我拆相机
Jake: Come help me take apart the camera.
Alice:ok
Alice: Okay.
Alice:拆相机
Alice: Take apart the camera.
Alice:趁我走之前
Alice: Before I leave.
Jake:你什么时候走
Jake: When are you leaving?
Alice:我嗯今天晚上
Alice: Uh, tonight.
Jake:吃完饭走是吧
Jake: After dinner, right?
Alice:嗯对
Alice: Yeah, that's right.
Lucia:吃吧吃吧
Lucia: Let's eat, let's eat.
Jake:你不是点了吗
Jake: Didn't you order?
Jake:你不吃
Jake: Aren't you eating?
Alice:点过了
Alice: I did order.
Alice:但是我你要说具体几点的话那无所谓
Alice: But if you want a specific time, it doesn't really matter.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh man.
Jake: 就转转先
Jake: Just turn it first.
Jake:先给它转一下
Jake: Turn it a bit first.
Jake:呃右边有一个
Jake: Uh, there's one on the right.
Alice:啊
Alice: Oh.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:那我来拆这个好不好
Lucia: How about I take this one apart?
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Sure, thanks.
Lucia:那么我就上桌了
Lucia: So I'll get on the table.
Jake:上桌
Jake: Get on the table.
Lucia:哎呀好激动呀
Lucia: Oh, so excited.
Lucia:好久没有上过桌了哈哈哈
Lucia: I haven't been on the table for so long, hahaha.
Lucia:所以是是就是撕下来么
Lucia: So, do I just tear this off?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:呃你你先拽下来你先把相机拽下来
Jake: Uh, you pull it down first, pull the camera down first.
Lucia:先把相机
Lucia: Pull the camera first?
Jake:拽拽拽拽
Jake: Pull, pull, pull.
Jake:它有一个这个口
Jake: There's this notch.
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my goodness.
Lucia:这样吗
Lucia: Like this?
Jake:还有一个这个东西
Jake: And there's this thing.
Alice:老板
Alice: Boss.
Alice:这个要是粘真的粘在墙上都得赔死了
Alice: If this sticks to the wall, it's going to cost a fortune to fix.
Jake:那可不能粘在墙
Jake: It can't stick to the wall.
Alice::巨巨黏
Alice: It's super sticky.
Jake: 对吧
Jake: Right?
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed
Lucia:哦我知道你说的哪个了嗯
Lucia: Oh, I know what you're talking about, yeah
Alice:这个怎么弄
Alice: How do I do this?
Lucia:我可以先把这个线
Lucia: I can start with this cable
Lucia:这线线连相机这头
Lucia: This cable connects to the camera
Lucia:我可以拔吗
Lucia: Can I unplug it?
Jake: 可以拔
Jake: Yes, you can
Lucia:因为感觉这个钮不是特别好转
Lucia: Because this knob doesn't turn well
Lucia:别我别我把线给它转断了
Lucia: I don't want to twist the cable until it breaks
Lucia:什么锁
Lucia: What lock?
Lucia:卫生所在
Lucia: The restroom is there
Lucia:我给你发个定位吧
Lucia: Let me send you the location
Alice:你怎么了
Alice: What's wrong with you?
Lucia:啊这个现在也不会不会掉下来
Lucia: Ah, this won't fall now
Alice:这个你打车去很慢
Alice: It's very slow to take a taxi
Alice:就是走路去很近
Alice: It's very close if you walk
Lucia:这现在不会掉下来吧
Lucia: This won't fall now, right?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Alice:哎呦我的妈
Alice: Oh my god
Lucia:我我去给雨轩发一下那个定位去
Lucia: I'll send the location to Yuxuan
Jake:咱陪他一起去
Jake: Let's go with him
Lucia:对
Lucia: Right
Lucia:要不然我送他过去
Lucia: Or I'll take him there
Lucia:因为我走过一次
Lucia: Because I've walked there once
Lucia:我比较熟
Lucia: I'm more familiar with it
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright
Alice:哎呦这个真的
Alice:这个黏的
Alice: This is sticky
Jake:哎呦我靠
Jake: Oh my god
Jake:这个这个
Jake: This, this
Lucia:我之前是发给发给那个同学
Lucia: I sent it to that classmate before
Lucia:叫什么来着
Lucia: What's the name again?
Lucia:就是染了头发
Lucia: The one who dyed their hair
Alice:XBZ
Alice: XBZ
Lucia:一下想不起来了
Lucia: Can't remember right now
Lucia:有点着急
Lucia: Kind of urgent
Jake:竹哥
Jake: Zhu Ge
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear
Alice:好难呢
Alice: This is hard
Lucia:找找一下我刚才的聊天记录
Lucia: Let me check our chat history
Jake:他现在是我哥
Jake: He's my brother now.
Jake:这这你你是我姐一样
Jake: Just like you are my sister.
Jake:哈哈 牛逼 哎呦
Jake: Haha, awesome, oh wow.
Alice:这个怎么弄下来
Alice: How do you take this down?
Alice:你可以给刘婷发个消息吗
Alice: Can you send a message to Liu Ting?
Alice:让她上来帮忙
Alice: Ask her to come up and help.
Jake:对先
Jake: Yeah, first
Jake:咱先救人
Jake: Let's save the person first.
Jake:他在哪啊
Jake: Where is he?
Jake:刘婷
Jake: Liu Ting?
Alice:楼底下呢
Alice: She's downstairs.
Jake:那一会要下去我叫她
Jake: I'll call her when we go down later.
Jake:嚯这个很顺利
Jake: Wow, this is going smoothly.
Alice:这个粘空调上的
Alice: This is stuck to the air conditioner.
Jake:我来试试
Jake: Let me try it.
Jake:let me try一下
Jake: Let me try一下.
Alice:你你试
Alice: You try it.
Jake:我试试
Jake: I'll try it.
Jake:我试试这个胶确实牛逼
Jake: I'll try, this glue is really awesome.
Jake:这胶可贵了
Jake: This glue is really expensive.
Alice:拆半天就拆这么点
Alice: You tried for so long and only did this much.
Lucia:呃我给你发了一个定位
Lucia: Uh, I sent you a location.
Jake:咱一块去吧好
Jake: Let's go together, okay?
Jake:就这么粗暴
Jake: Just this rough.
Alice:但是那个呢
Alice: But what about that?
Jake:不管
Jake: Doesn't matter.
Alice:啊
Alice: Huh?
Jake:没有
Jake: Nothing.
Jake:就这个这个
Jake: Just this, this.
Jake:问问管别墅的人他们有没有法子
Jake: Ask the people who manage the villa if they have any solutions.
Jake:他们可能拆过这种东西
Jake: They might have taken this kind of stuff apart before.
Alice:什么干啥
Alice: What are you talking about?
Jake:就是我们撕完之后他剩下来一个
Jake: After we peel it off, it leaves this behind.
Lucia:哦这个这个可能可以啊OK
Lucia: Oh, this, this might work, okay.
Jake:这个已经没了
Jake: This one is gone.
Jake:哦这个这个
Jake: Oh, this, this.
Lucia:那个可能可以用
Lucia: That one might be useful.
Lucia:就是吹风机吹一下
Lucia: Just blow it with a hairdryer.
Lucia:然后看能不能撕下来
Lucia: Then see if it can be peeled off.
Lucia:但是不是100%能成功
Lucia: But it's not 100% guaranteed to work.
Jake:OK OK问问他问问他
Jake: OK OK, ask him, ask him.
Jake:谢谢各位帮忙做苦力
Jake: Thanks everyone for helping with the heavy lifting.
Alice:啊呀
Jake:这纯纯大苦力
Jake: This is pure heavy labor.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey.
Lucia:哎呀
Lucia: Oh no.
Jake:我又靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:这边卫生所设施怎么样
Jake: How are the facilities at the health center here?
Lucia:呃呃好有点一言难尽
Lucia: Uh, well, it's a bit complicated to explain.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Lucia:大家一会看一眼
Lucia: Everyone can take a look later.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh.
Lucia:要不要采药吗
Lucia: Do you want to collect herbs?
Jake:也可以采一下
Jake: We could do that too.
Lucia:没事小小小小问题
Lucia: No worries, it's a small issue.
Lucia:他们肯定那个什么
Lucia: They will definitely, you know...
Lucia:就是那个卫生所他在装修
Lucia: The health center is under renovation.
Alice:干啥
Alice: What are you doing?
刘婷:拉我一把我脚都麻了
Liu Ting: Give me a hand, my foot is numb.
Alice:你干什么来
Alice: What are you doing here?
Lucia:我伞在箱子里
Lucia: My umbrella is in the box.
刘婷:哈哈哈哈稍安勿躁
Liu Ting: Hahaha, calm down.
刘婷:稍安勿躁
Liu Ting: Calm down.
刘婷:我的
Liu Ting: Mine.
Alice:哈哈哈你别挡道
Alice: Hahaha, don't block the way.
Alice:要去要去医院哈哈哈
Alice: We need to go to the hospital, hahaha.
Alice:老玩这抽象
Alice: Always being so abstract.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:你先坐那吧
Alice: Just sit there for now.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:来来来
Alice: Come on, come on.
Alice:坐
Alice: Sit.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:嗯待会还得下去
Alice: Hmm, we still have to go down later.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey.
Alice:都弄掉
Alice: Get rid of them all.
Jake:要大家捐
Jake: We need everyone to donate.
Jake:捐几件衣服
Jake: Donate some clothes.
Jake:怕你冷着
Jake: So you don't get cold.
Alice:上面是不是拆完了
Alice: Is everything upstairs demolished?
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Jake:就放到那桌上
Jake: Just put it on that table.
Alice:下面吧
Alice: How about below?
Jake:下面三人还是别拆了
Jake: The three below, better not unpack.
Alice:告诉你一个消息
Alice: I've got some news for you.
Alice:刘婷我要下去了
Alice: Liu Ting, I'm going down.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:来
Alice: Come on.
刘婷:处心机虑把我骗下去
Liu Ting: You tricked me into coming down here.
Alice:不是我没给你发消息
Alice: No, I didn't message you.
Alice:你咋上来了
Alice: How did you get up here?
刘婷:因为
Liu Ting: Because...
Alice:你听见了
Alice: You heard it.
Lucia:哦你不是让我给刘婷发消息么
Lucia: Oh, didn't you ask me to message Liu Ting?
Alice:对啊我还以为我俩的脑电波交流了
Alice: Yeah, I thought we were on the same wavelength.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:那是真的
Jake: That's true.
Alice:我我我去吧
Alice: I'll go.
Jake:你你别动啊
Jake: You, don't move.
Jake:你你
Jake: You, you...
Alice:我去吧
Alice: I'll go.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Alice:她在哪啊
Alice: Where is she?
Katrina: 53号房
Katrina: Room 53.
Jake:雨轩你在哪
Jake: Yuxuan, where are you?
Alice:53号房在哪
Alice: Where is Room 53?
Katrina: 我就不该吃东西的
Katrina: I shouldn't have eaten.
Alice:你是不是急性
Alice: Do you have acute...
Alice:肠胃炎呢
Alice: Gastroenteritis?
Alice:可能是感觉像是
Alice: Maybe, it feels like it.
Alice:5 53号楼在哪里
Alice: Where is Building 53?
Alice:好像知道又好像不知道
Alice: I kind of know, but kind of don't.
Jake:哎左拐
Jake: Hey, turn left.
Alice:这
Alice: Here?
Jake:左拐对
Jake: Turn left, right.
Alice:这是左
Alice: Is this left?
Jake:哎嗯
Jake: Yes, uh-huh.
Jake:就你第一回拿快递
Jake: Is this your first time picking up a package?
Alice:不是
Alice: No.
Jake:第一回拿外卖
Jake: First time getting takeout?
Alice:不是啊
Alice: No, it's not.
Jake:那那那你
Jake: Then, then, then you...
Alice:但是他说53我就不知道在哪
Alice: But he said 53, I don't know where that is.
Jake:我31他到门口去了
Jake: I'm 31, he went to the door.
Jake:这就是53
Jake: This is 53.
Alice:都是他们家的吗
Alice: Is all of this their house?
Jake:对这一排都是他们家
Jake: Yes, this whole row is their house.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Alice:是
Alice: Yes.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Jake:没了
Jake: That's it.
Alice:没了
Alice: That's it.
Jake:慢走 有吧
Jake: Take care, got it?
Jake:啊 有啊 哎呦
Jake: Ah, got it, oh.
Jake:这个这单多远
Jake: How far is this order?
外卖员:看一下你们这个啊
Delivery person: Let me check for you.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
外卖员:应该没多完
Delivery person: It shouldn't be far.
Jake:拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye.
Alice:含湖在哪 不知道
Alice:这一排都是他们家
Alice: This whole row is their house.
Jake:啊  说什么
Jake: Ah, what did you say?
Lucia:我们去卫生所
Lucia: We're going to the clinic.
Lucia:路上还要需要录这个吗
Lucia: Do we need to keep recording on the way?
Lucia:还是可以停掉之类的
Lucia: Or can we stop it or something?
Jake:你再带着吧
Jake: Just keep it on.
Jake:带着没电拉倒了就
Jake: If it runs out of battery, that's it.
Lucia:哈哈哈 行行 那
Lucia: Haha, okay, then...
Lucia:呃那个不远
Lucia: Uh, it's not far.
Alice:走路十分钟吧
Alice: It's a ten-minute walk.
Jake:好 有什么要帮忙的我们就冲过去啊
Jake: Alright, if you need any help, we'll rush over.
Jake:暂且我们先派您一个
Jake: For now, we'll send you one person.
Jake:带了伞吗
Jake: Did you bring an umbrella?
Alice:带了
Alice: Yes, I did.
Alice: 嗯这怎么关呢
Alice: Hmm, how do you turn this off?
Alice:是不是得先关了
Alice: Do I have to turn it off first?
Alice: 我害怕怎么办
Alice: What if I'm scared?
Alice: 无所谓反正我装了
Alice: It doesn't matter, I already installed it.
Jake: 给您端馄饨
Jake: I'll bring you some wontons.
Alice: 这个需要先关掉吗
Alice: Do I need to turn this off first?
Alice: 哪一个
Alice: Which one?
Alice:这些
Alice: These ones?
Jake:这些
Jake: These ones?
Jake: 不 这些这些
Jake: No, these ones, these ones.
Jake: 等到他们没
Jake: Wait until they're...
Jake: 呃没没没story了
Jake: Uh, when they're out of stories.
Jake: 就停止
Jake: Then stop.
Jake: 让他们再贡献最后一些小数据
Jake: Let them contribute some last bits of data.
Alice:力量
Alice: Strength.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 嗯我不知道哪个是我的呀
Jake: Hmm, I don't know which one is mine.
Alice: 哈哈哈 不要的 这是不要香菜的
Alice: Hahaha, no, this one doesn't have cilantro.
Alice: 哎
Alice: Hey.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我们有很多不要香菜的
Jake: We have a lot without cilantro.
Alice: 你是哪个
Alice: Which one is yours?
Tasha:我没要
Tasha: I didn't order one.
Alice:你没点吗
Alice: You didn't order?
Jake: 她没点但是嗯
Jake: She didn't order, but, um...
刘婷:没事的没事 给你 匀一碗
Liu Ting: It's okay, it's okay. I'll share a bowl with you.
Alice: 匀点 你要香菜还是不要
Alice: Share some. Do you want cilantro or not?
Tasha:我不要的
Tasha: I don't want it.
Alice: 啊那我们都可以给你匀
Alice: Ah, then we can all share with you.
Jake: 别选雨萱的 没法吃
Jake: Don't take Yuxuan's, it's inedible.
Alice: 他是什么时候开始的
Alice: When did he start?
Jake: 我不知道时候开始的
Jake: I don't know when he started.
Jake: 她是想吃这个
Jake: She wants to eat this.
Jake: 但是她已经上卫生所
Jake: But she already went to the clinic.
Jake: 并且她应该吃了她就吐所以没法吃
Jake: And if she eats it, she'll probably throw up, so she can't eat it.
Alice:看上去像肠胃炎
Alice: Looks like gastroenteritis.
Jake: 一般是吃坏了还是怎么着
Jake: Usually from eating bad food or something?
Alice: 不一定很多吧
Alice: Not necessarily, a lot of reasons.
Alice: 主要是肠胃
Alice: Mainly the stomach.
Tasha:吃太杂了吧好像是
Tasha: Ate too much variety, I think.
Jake: 哦伙食太好了
Jake: Oh, the food was too good.
Tasha:这点菜一点叶子也没有
Tasha: This dish doesn't have a single leaf.
Alice: 嗯可能是
Alice: Yeah, maybe.
Jake: 真的
Jake: Really.
Alice: 就容易缺维生素之类的
Alice: It's easy to lack vitamins and stuff.
Alice:下巴老冒痘
Alice: Breaking out on the chin.
Jake: 中午今天中午有菜对吧
Jake: There are dishes for lunch today, right?
Alice:今天中午吃的啥呀
Alice: What are we having for lunch today?
Alice: 哦有但是挺油的 无妨
Alice: Oh, there are, but they're quite greasy. Never mind.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright then.
Jake:香菜
Jake: Cilantro.
Jake:是这个味
Jake: This is the flavor.
Jake: 嗯那你那你别过来
Jake: Hmm, you, you don't come over here.
Alice: 你是哪个
Alice: Which one are you?
Alice: 我也不知道你是哪个
Alice: I don't even know which one you are.
刘婷:嗯什么虾仁不要香菜的这两都是
Liu Ting: Hmm, which shrimp doesn't have cilantro, these two both don't.
Alice: 都不要香菜的吧
Alice: Both don't have cilantro, right?
Jake: 你怎么知道的
Jake: How do you know?
Alice: 没有那个绿色
Alice: There's no green stuff.
Alice: 这俩都没啊
Alice: These two don't have it.
刘婷:啊没事我要不要香菜其实都可以
Liu Ting: Ah, it's okay, I don't really mind cilantro.
Jake: 不是就是这馅怎么看啊
Jake: No, how do you tell what the filling is?
刘婷:这馅 应该是肉馅
Liu Ting: The filling? It should be meat.
Jake: 有很多种肉馅吧
Jake: There are many kinds of meat fillings, right?
Alice:看一下
Alice: Let's take a look.
Jake: 哦你想吃菜是吧
Jake: Oh, you want vegetables, right?
Alice:没纸
Jake: 这个是菜
Jake: This one is vegetables.
刘婷:哦不是我真不吃
Liu Ting: Oh, no, I really don't eat that.
Jake: 那你好吧
Jake: Alright then.
Tasha:我把露亚的吃了应该
Tasha: I think I ate Lucia's.
Jake: 你咋知道这是露亚的
Jake: How do you know it's Lucia's?
Tasha:我猜的
Tasha: I guessed.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 这个虾仁的
Alice: This one's shrimp.
Jake: 我不记得我点的是啥
Jake: I don't remember what I ordered.
Jake: 剩下的就给我吧
Jake: Just give me the leftovers.
Jake: 你不吃
Jake: You're not eating?
Alice: 我靠香菜
Alice: I can't stand cilantro.
Jake: 给你吃一个吧
Jake: Have one anyway.
Alice: 香菜哈
Alice: Cilantro, huh.
Alice: 就这样吧随便了
Alice: Whatever, it's fine.
刘婷:没事反正也没有很多吧
Liu Ting: It's okay, it's not much anyway.
Jake: 哎哎哎哎哎
Jake: Hey, hey, hey.
刘婷:慢点慢点
Liu Ting: Slow down, slow down.
Jake: 哎 我来我来
Jake: Hey, I'll do it.
Jake: 哎哎
Alice: 这样吧我抽到了香菜款
Alice: Alright, I got the cilantro one.
Tasha:原来香菜在下面
Tasha: So the cilantro was at the bottom.
Alice:嗯就这样吧
Alice: Yeah, just like that.
Jake: 给张纸是吧
Jake: Do you need a tissue?
Jake: 我来问问XBZ他在干嘛
Jake: Let me ask XBZ what he's doing.
Tasha:他什么时时候来
Tasha: When is he coming?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Lucia:好像就差不多这
Lucia: Seems like it's about this.
Jake:这谁知道
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey
Jake: 哎竹哥竹哥竹哥
Jake: Hey, Bamboo, Bamboo, Bamboo
Jake: 你在哪啊
Jake: Where are you?
Jake: 竹哥 对
Jake: Bamboo, yeah
Lucia: 就从这出去
Lucia: Just go out from here.
Lucia: 然后就到了很近
Lucia: Then you'll reach, it's very close.
Jake: 你一个人来的是吧
Jake: You came alone, right?
Jake: 你发烧你一个人坐地铁呢
Jake: You have a fever and you're taking the subway alone?
Jake: 你这么牛逼
Jake: You're so tough.
Jake: 你退你退烧了啊
Jake: Did your fever go down?
Alice: 退烧了
Alice: Yes, it's gone.
Jake:你退烧了啊
Jake: Your fever is gone?
Tasha:马不停蹄跑过来打工
Tasha: Rushed over here to work non-stop.
Jake: 行行好好退
Jake: Okay, okay, good, it's down.
Jake: 哈哈哈不
Jake: Hahaha no
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 我不觉得你过来是睡觉的
Jake: I don't think you came here to sleep.
Alice:太少了
Alice: Too little.
Jake: 行吧
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 呃你什么时候来的
Jake: Uh, when did you arrive?
Jake: 你什么时候到
Jake: When did you get here?
Jake: 大概8点半
Jake: Around 8:30.
Alice: 好你吃晚饭了吗
Alice: Okay, did you have dinner?
Jake: 啊自己吃了
Jake: Yeah, I ate by myself.
Alice: 哎我们还可以点了吗
Alice: Can we still order?
Jake: 哎可惜了只能帮你吃了
Jake: Ah, too bad, I'll have to eat for you.
Jake: 好再见吧
Jake: Okay, goodbye.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake: 哈哈哈行拜拜
Jake: Hahaha, okay, bye.
Jake: 拜拜拜拜拜拜
Jake: Bye bye bye bye
Jake: 来来点来一个
Jake: Come on, let's get one.
Tasha:那我这个吃一个
Tasha: Then I'll eat this one.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 给给你个勺
Jake: Here, take a spoon.
Tasha:不用了我不用了
Tasha: No, I don't need it.
Jake: 咱就不缺勺
Jake: We have plenty of spoons.
Jake: 行给你个筷子
Jake: Fine, take some chopsticks.
Tasha:我也不用
Tasha: I don't need those either.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:唉不对那怎么吃
Tasha: Wait, how do I eat it then?
Jake: 就是嘛
Jake: Exactly.
Tasha:啊谢谢
Tasha: Oh, thanks.
Jake: 啊我筷子刚给你弄好
Jake: I just got the chopsticks ready for you.
Jake: 你就好这个是是捎给你的是吧
Jake: You like this, right? It's for you.
Jake: 好吃吗
Jake: Is it tasty?
Jake: 怎么一脸凝重
Jake: Why do you look so serious?
Alice: 呵呵嗯 不是
Alice: Haha, no, it's not that.
Tasha:这么难吃吗
Tasha: Is it that bad?
Alice:因为抽到香菜款了
Alice: I got the cilantro flavor.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Really?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Jake: 香菜款所以不是
Jake: Cilantro flavor, so that's why.
Alice: 这个皮有点厚
Alice: The skin is a bit thick.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 你觉得呢
Alice: What do you think?
Jake: 没吃到呢
Jake: I haven't tried it yet.
刘婷:但味道还行
Liu Ting: But the taste is okay.
Jake: 你俩怎么认识的
Jake: How did you two meet?
Alice: 命中注定认识的
Alice: It was destined.
Alice:我靠干嘛
Alice: Oh my, what are you doing?
Jake:怎么怎么找着的
Jake: How did you find each other?
Alice: 阴差阳错当了邻居
Alice: By a twist of fate, we became neighbors.
Alice: 我真服了
Alice: I really can't believe it.
Alice: 我能换个味吗
Alice: Can I switch flavors?
Jake: 晚上发生的啥
Jake: What happened that night?
Alice: 什么晚上发生的
Alice: What happened that night?